TO DO A RIDE-ALONG
WITH THE POLICE,
'CAUSE I'M WRITING A COP NOVEL.
- COOL.
- WOW.
- GRITTY STUFF.
- I BET, DUDE.
- BUT ALICE WANTED ME
TO STOP BY FOR THE ROAST.
- ROAST? WHAT ROAST?
- YEAH.
- OH, MONDAY IS BILL'S
20TH ANNIVERSARY
OF WORKING AT TELAMERICORP,
SO WE'RE ROASTING HIM.
- COOL. YEAH.
- OH, NICE.
- ALL RIGHT, SO, LIKE,
HOW MANY SNAPS SHOULD WE WRITE?
- YEAH, CAN WE WORK BLUE?
CAN WE CUSS?
- AND ALSO, WHO'S BILL?
- OH, ACTUALLY, ALICE SAID
YOU GUYS DON'T GET
TO DO THE ROAST.
- REALLY?
- UH, WHY WOULDN'T
THE THREE FUNNIEST GUYS
IN THE OFFICE BE ROASTING HIM?
- YOU'RE NOT FUNNY.
[all scoff]
- I'M NOT FUNNY?
ME?
ADAM, "THE--THE LAUGH KI--
THE LAUGH--UH...
GIVER" DEMAMP.
- MM-HMM.
- I KNOW ALL 101 SICK JOKES
FOR TWISTED KIDS.
- OH, ALICE,
YOU WANT TO KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A PILE OF DEAD BABIES
AND A PILE OF SAND?
- I DON'T EAT SAND.
[laughter]
- [scoffs]
FINE. WHATEVER.
- YOU'LL LET US ROAST?
- YES.
[cheering]
- YES! NICE.
- YES.
- SO COOL. I GOT THIS THING...
- HEY, YOU HONESTLY
DON'T THINK I'M FUNNY?
JUST ME,
NOT TALKING ABOUT THOSE GUYS.
- YOU'VE HONESTLY NEVER SAID
ONE THING I HAVE EVER FOUND
AT ALL FUNNY, BRO.
- [scoffs]
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT FUNNY?
CHICKS AREN'T FUNNY.
DUDES ARE FUNNY.
HANGOVER 2 RULES.
BRIDESMAIDS DROOLS.